welcome back the Mayan experience in
Henderson is the only simulated
underground mine in the state and this
weekend they're having their annual
Hidden Gem Gala and here to tell us more
is Phil Luna he's the executive director
welcome to the show Phil thank you for
having me uh it's great to see you again
tell everyone about the Mayan experience
what do you have going out there so my
experience is a family-friendly
destination we've got a visitor center
and we've got interactive Hands-On
exhibits so people could come and and
really experience what mining was like
in history as well as modern mining
we've had over a hundred thousand
students come through the mine
experience because they really come to
see our gym which is our simulated
underground gold mine yeah you have an
actual mine there's some footage of you
and I walking through the mine I went
out there last month and this thing is
so impressive who built the thing well
it was actually built by by local
companies here but one of the ones who
helped design it helped design the
Indiana Jones ride down at Disneyland it
has that Disney filter I was out there
for about four or five hours of the
filming and it's so educational it's
entertaining and I only feel like it was
the tip of the iceberg there's so much
to see out there at the Mind experience
but this Saturday is a big Gala what's
happening at the gala well I want to
invite everybody to come out for this
Saturday this September the 24th at 6 PM
is our Hidden Gem Gala and silent
auction and we're gonna have an amazing
night we've got singer nieve malandra
who's going to be there we have
headliner Murray the magician who's
going to be performing and it's just
going to be a great time for you to
experience the Mind experience and win
amazing prizes it's going to be and
helping the mind out it's all for a
great cause there and he brought some
stuff here that you have on display
there you have a canary in a cage tell
me more about this well these are all
things having to do with either historic
mining or modern mining but this one is
uh really special to us this canary uh
they used to take canaries into the mine
to detect bad air you heard the story
back in the day so the canary dies you
know get out the air is bad as long as
it's singing then it's good yeah when it
stops singing then you know that it's
bad and so that would help the miners it
was a tremendously important uh safety
feature today we don't have birds in the
mine anymore but we have these canaries
these technology has given us these new
devices and uh so now these detect the
bad air it saves lives and it also saves
the lives of canaries that's right and
what's this thing right here before we
wrap up here what's this thing this is
another piece of safety equipment here
that's used uh whenever there's bad air
so that you can breathe and and make it
out of the Mind safely that's the number
one important thing to mining companies
is safety in the mind and you learn that
when you go out to the mine experience
there in Henderson and lastly here these
gems why do we have gems on the table
well the gems aren't because uh these
are things that are mined in Nevada mine
so much but they are are to remind
people about our Hidden Gem Gala that's
coming up and and silent auction and so
we're actually going to be hiding these
around our property and the people that
find them are going to win surprises
including some silver coins and some
awesome some copper coins and things and
uh it's good it's just going to be a
blast Phil thank you so much for joining
us appreciate it thank you it's gonna be
a lot of fun so Saturday it's the Hidden
Gem Gala in silent auction it's this
Saturday at the mine experience to
purchase tickets visit mccallmines.org